the White House is ordering new
sanctions on Russia over Kremlin
cyberattacks against the US and attempts
to meddle in the u.s. election the
Treasury Department is targeting seven
oligarchs with ties to President
Vladimir Putin 17 Russian government
officials and a dozen Russian companies
Paula Reed is at the White House with
the very latest Paula good morning good
morning congressional leaders on both
sides of the aisle applauded the
administration's action but said it was
long overdue there's nobody been tougher
on Russia days after President Trump
said he could have a great relationship
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
the White House announced new sanctions
on Russian oligarchs officials and
companies connected to Putin freezing
assets and restricting business with
American companies what we would like to
see is the totality of the Russian
behavior change the White House said the
sanctions are a response to Russian
aggression including arming Syrian
regime seizing Crimea in eastern Ukraine
and meddling in the u.s. election in
Friday's announcement Treasury secretary
Steve minuchin said the Russian
government engages in a range of Millian
activity around the globe the sanctions
target Vladimir Putin's inner circle
including a man believed to be his
son-in-law and Oleg Deripaska an
aluminum billionaire whose ties to the
president's former campaign chairman
Paul Manafort have placed him in special
counsel Robert Muller's Russia
investigation mr. Putin may believe that
he is winning in this new form of
warfare outgoing National Security
Advisor HR McMaster spoke out earlier
this week against Russian aggression
citing Russian cyber attacks and the
poisoning of a former Russian spy in
Great Britain
perhaps he believes that our free
nations are weak and will not respond
will not respond to his provocations he
is wrong the White House says that these
sanctions will not prevent the president
from holding a proposed summit with
Putin something the president proposed
weeks ago but of course whether or not
that summit actually occurs that will
depend on how Russia response to these
sanctions Anthony
Paula Reid at the White House this
morning thanks Paula